this week on newsmakers senator Bernie
Sanders independent of Vermont joining
us from that state but member of the
Budget Committee as well and to
reporters to help us with questions
Kevin Drawbaugh Reuters and Laura
Meckler of the Wall Street Journal Kevin
let me begin with you first question
senator Sanders before the all the names
for the super committee came out it felt
like there was a moment here in
Washington where people felt like this
committee might be able to achieve some
sort of grand bargain meaning you know
bipartisan agreement on taxes and
spending cuts but since the names have
come out mostly hardliners from the
Republicans and sort of policy
lieutenants from the Democrats the mood
is shifted back to you know maybe this
is just another round of deadlock what
do you think is this a breakthrough
moment or more the same well I look at
it a little bit differently the way I
see it is in the last three negotiations
that we had going back to December and
in terms of tax extensions in terms of
when the Republicans in April threatened
to shut down the government and then the
recent debt ceiling issue I think the
Republicans kind of won all three of
those negotiations hands down I think
most people consider that that to be the
case my view is that right now what the
Democrats have got to do is remain
strong I protect Social Security
Medicare and Medicaid and the
Republicans I believe I've got to do
with the overwhelming majority the
American people wanting in every poll
that we have seen and that is you have
to have shared sacrifice you have to
have the wealthiest people in this
country who are doing phenomenally well
and their effective tax rate is the
lowest in decades large corporations who
many cases are making billions in
profits sometimes pay nothing in taxes
they have got to contribute to deficit
reduction and if they choose not to do
that and I think you know almost all of
the Republicans on this committee have
made their pledge the grove in norcross
I'm not quite sure what kind of progress
you're going to have senator let me ask
you about the the Democratic side though
of the six Democrats that have been
named
which ones which one might give you
pause that they could deal with the
other side and who do you have
confidence in well I certainly know all
the you know the three folks in the
Senate and they're all smart and strong
people like no they house folks as well
I would simply hope that the Democrats
hang together and that they demand
fairness and they demand policies that
help us create the kinds of jobs that we
desperately need in this economy but we
cannot continue to surrender it to the
Republicans who say yeah we have a
deficit problem but we don't want the
wealthiest people in this country
millionaires and billionaires to
contribute one penny more nor do we want
large profitable corporations that
contribute it has to come completely out
of the backs of working families the
elderly the sick and the children the
Democrats have got to say no that cannot
be the case that's not what the American
people want so I would hope the
Democrats hold firm and maybe for a
change the Republicans do some yelling
so if the Republicans were willing to
give up taxes and we're willing to to do
some of the things that you just talked
about would you be willing to see
reductions in Social Security Medicare
Medicaid as a trader always I think
there are all ways that you can move
toward deficit reduction but in fact I
don't think you have to hit those three
programs i think there are other
programs though i would prefer not to
see cut but i think may have to be cut
uh throughout across the board i will
tell you this that we have tripled
funding for defense since 1997 we're now
spending about a hundred and sixty
billion dollars a year still fighting
the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan we have
many weapons systems out there that were
designed to fight the old Cold War and
not international terrorism so I happen
to believe that we can make very
significant cuts in military spending as
part of deficit reduction while still
retaining our military strong military
presence there are other programs in
agriculture and across the board I think
you can cut but I don't know how you cut
Medicaid when you got 50 million people
today without
health insurance I don't know what you
do about Medicare Medicare you can make
some changes without reducing benefits
that I would be open to that for example
right now we don't negotiate drug prices
I think there's a lot of savings to be
made in Medicare if we did what we do
with the VA in negotiations with the
drug companies there are improvements
that can be made but the idea for
example that some have floated about
raising the eligibility level 267 is
basically insane what do you do if
you're 66 and your low income and you're
sick with cancer what does that mean
it's a death sentence and if I could not
support that senators and let me bring
you back to taxes as much as you say
that the Republicans are entrenched in
there no new taxes position colleague of
mine at Reuters spoke with Dave camp
yesterday the chairman of the House Ways
and Means Committee he said everything's
on the table as far as he's concerned
including tax policy Pat Toomey who is a
tea party favorite said yesterday that
there are quote indefensible tax breaks
that need to be looked at is there room
for some sort of maybe even symbolic tax
break closures here in this negotiation
well I would certainly hope so I'm glad
to hear some of these guys saying that
but I feared that at the end of the day
I may be wrong and I and I hope that
they are sincere about that but as you
well know the devil is in the details
what many of these guys believe in which
I don't is trickle-down economics and
that is a few lower tax rates for large
corporations which is what they want to
do uh that somehow magically we create
millions of jobs and everybody lives
happily ever after I happen not to
believe in the trickle-down economic
theory I think it benefits upper income
people but if they are open to do look
we know that there are large
multinational corporations who make
billions in profits who pay sometimes
nothing in taxes we know that we're
losing about a hundred billion dollars a
year through the wealthy and large
corporations stashing their money in the
cayman islands and in Bermuda and
another tax havens if these guys the
Republicans are willing to look at those
areas to raise revenue for our country
uh I would be very delighted and
certainly hope that that happens as you
know if this super committee does not
come up with an agreement there is a
trigger that kicks in where some
automatic spending cuts kick in about a
trillion dollars of additional spending
cuts and about half of that would be
from defense a lot of defense Hawks say
that would be cutting way too deeply but
perhaps you see it differently and I'm
wondering if you might prefer the the
trigger to be enacted rather than you
know sort of roll the dice with whatever
this bipartisan your so-called
supercommittee comes up with well it's a
question of rolling the dice what I
prefer the sequestration approach if you
ended up with a bad deal that cut Social
Security Medicare and Medicaid and
wrecked havoc with programs that working
families desperately need sure I would
prefer sequestration to that on the
other hand if the committee could come
up with a package that was fair and
responsible that called for shared
sacrifice that protected the needs of
ordinary people I would support that one
of the things that I've been really
concerned about I think you know the
media talks about a trillion here in a
trillion there we don't talk about what
these cuts mean to people in the real
world we're talking about the
possibility of massive cuts in child
care and in head start at a time when we
have a child care disaster we're talking
about massive cuts in college grants
when people can't afford to send their
kids to college we're talking about
decimating the Environmental Protection
Agency when we're trying to combat
global warming we're talking about cuts
and nutrition programs when we're seeing
an increase in hunger among children and
the elderly so I think we got to add
flesh and blood what are we really
talking about we're in the midst of a
horrendous recession people are hurting
and if you start cutting all of these
programs there's going to be pain and
there's going to be death so I think we
have to make sure that that does not
happen what did you think of the
Democratic Senate appointments to the
super committee patty Murray John Kerry
Max Baucus could Harry Reid have made
some better choices I think I thought I
heard you say earlier in the week you
would have liked to serve on the
committee yourself well you know I
I know you know John Max and Patty quite
well all of them are very very smart
their experience they are knowledgeable
my guess is that there will be a lot of
discussion between the committee members
and the caucus I don't think they're
going to be out there all on their own
and then coming up with a package I
think there's going to be discussion uh
and as I said earlier I hope at the end
of the day what they will be able to
accomplish is to get the Republicans
finally to understand that when our
country that has the most unequal
distribution of income and wealth of any
major country and that gap between the
very rich and everybody else is growing
wider that those folks on top are going
to have to contribute to deficit
reduction I hope I hope very much they
stay strong on that Senator the I think
in the one of the papers this week
called labeled Max Baucus a centrist
would you calm a centrist and if so what
does that mean to you in these
negotiations for the super committee
well look if you're asking me what I
have appointed three different people I
probably would have but you know max
baucus's chairman of the Finance
Committee he's a pretty smart guy I
think for the right reasons by the way
he was on the bowles-simpson Commission
as I recall he voted against it which I
think was the right vote but again I
think it's wrong to think that these
guys are going to be living in a world
of their own you know patty Murray is
the chair of the Senate Democrats on the
committee she is part of leadership I
think you're going to see a lot of
discussion taking place between the
caucus and those three folks um speaking
of Paul Simpson we have the bold Simpson
report which recommended reductions to
entitlements and increased tax revenue
you then had the Gang of Six proposal
which did the same sort of building on
bull Simpson and a similar type of
proposal and now you have President
Obama making the case almost on a
recently on a daily basis that we need
to compromise and have a balanced
package and in his mind what a balanced
package means is cuts and entitlements
and increases in tax revenues is
the president fundamentally wrong that
that's where the middle is and that's
where the compromise again you know I
think most Americans believe that in
fact the president and and the Democrats
have compromised far too much and the
Republicans have given virtually nothing
I think and you can correct me if i'm
wrong i think john boehner said after
this deficit reduction package was
passed that he got ninety eight percent
of what he wanted Paul Ryan said he got
seventy-five percent of what he wanted I
didn't hear any Democrats most thing
about what they got they didn't get
anything so I think the record in the
last half years is the Democrats have
compromised but let me get back to
President Obama when President Obama ran
for office what he said is vote for me
not John McCain because among other
reasons John became wants to cut your
Social Security benefits what the
president understands and has said and
his administration have said Social
Security hasn't contributed one penny to
our deficit Social Security compared
every benefit for the next 25 years
Social Security trust fund is a two
point six trillion dollar surplus why in
god's name would anybody including the
president talked about cutting social
security when if all we have to do is
lift the cap on people making $250,000
or more we can solve the problem for 75
years so if the president wants to do
that is going back on a campaign promise
and he's doing something which the
Republicans have always wanted to do so
what Bush talked about so I think that
that is a mistake so if you ask me about
compromise sure everybody has got to
compromise but when you have the richest
people in this country doing
phenomenally well corporate profits
phenomenally high wall street back to
where they were before they cause this
recession you know what that's to be a
whole lot of give on that side before
you tell the elderly and the sick and
the children who are hurting today that
they have got to give more so back in
december of last year you went on the
Senate floor and made a remarkable
speech lasted eight and a half hours I
think it was talking about these very
topics are you more or less frustrated
now than
you were then I mean if things got
better or worse between now and then
well I think if you read the book that
came out of that speech what you will
find that I and I say this a bit sadly
that I kind of predicted pretty much of
what would happen and what I said
essentially in December and the debate
in December the Republicans were saying
we will not extend unemployment benefits
to significant numbers of people who are
about to lose them and what ended up
happening is the president surrendered
on whether or not we would extend the
tax Bush tax breaks for the wealthy and
in fact also even lowered the tax rates
on estate taxes for the top three tenths
of one percent and what I said if when
you had in December a Democratic
president a Democratic Senate and then a
democratic house if you couldn't win
under those political circumstances how
in God's name but we got to win when
right-wing Republicans were controlling
the house unfortunately that is exactly
what happened in the Democrats have been
caving in and caving in since I think
most people do understand that so where
we are right now I think with our mop
the mystical pessimistic I think the
American people have to stand up very
clearly all over this country and say no
no you're not going to cut Social
Security let's be clear you know this
so-called chained CPI which they're
talking about you go out and you tell
seen yesterday do it say oh by the way
there are folks in Washington who think
your Cola today which you have not
received the last two years despite the
fact that your prescription drug costs
than your health care costs of risen
they think that's too generous and what
they want to do is wait if you're 65 now
when you're 75 take back about five
hundred and sixty dollars that otherwise
would have gotten and when you're 85 a
thousand dollars see how seniors feel
about that so this division on fiscal
policy between Democrats and Republicans
so deeply entrenched can we expect this
to carry on right into
the election campaign can Americans
expect many more months of this sort of
confrontation because both parties seem
intent on hashing this out right into
the campaign make and making the
election almost a referendum on their
positions is that your expectation well
I well I I think the truth is you have
very very different philosophies and
while needless to say I strongly
strongly strongly disagree with the
Republican ideology which is designed in
my view to protect the wealthiest people
in this country and the largest
corporations and is designed to take
away many of the programs that working
families have fought for for the last 80
years what I have to say is I do respect
their willingness to stand up and fight
they said that we will not support one
nickel of new taxes for millionaires and
billionaires and for large corporations
you know what they've kept their word I
think it's a disaster for the country
but they have to be complimented I
contrast that to some Democrats
including the president who said well
when I run for office this is what I'm
telling you but now guess what I've
changed my mind so I do think that you
have philosophical differences i think
trickle-down economic theory cuts in
Social Security Medicare Medicaid
infrastructure everybody in America
understands there's something
fundamentally wrong what we have an
infrastructure which is collapsing we're
not putting people to work rebuilding
that when we can create millions of
good-paying jobs everybody understands
that we can make huge progress
transforming our energy system into
energy efficiency and sustainable energy
not spend 350 billion a year importing
oil you know everybody most people
understand that our trade policies which
has resulted in shutdown after shutdown
of American plants we've lost fifty
thousand factories in the last ten years
millions of good-paying jobs now I know
my friends on the wall street journal
editorial page do not agree with me nor
in the New York Times editorial page go
out on Main Street and ask people how
they feel about the current trade
policies and what they've done to the
American economy where companies have
transferred millions of jobs to
don't know the third world countries we
need to be talking about in the
background though there are you know
these sort of huge economic and
financial events taking place Standard &
Poor's downgrading us credit rating for
the first time in history these gigantic
swings in the stock market they're
chasing all sorts of investors
completely out of the market it's a
possibility that these events could just
overtake the political discussion here
in Washington and Joel people out of
their their partisan positions well you
know I don't like to what people need to
be discussing as a nation is where we
want to go uh again I I strongly
disagree with the Republicans but they
have been consistent about their beliefs
the American people are going to have to
decide as soon as possible whether they
really do believe that tax breaks for
billionaires and cuts in Social Security
and Medicare and Medicaid and a trade
policy which causes millions of jobs is
really what we can do as a nation and
survive economically so I would agree
with you that we are in the midst of a
great debate and I think these are
issues that have to be discussed you're
one of a number of prominent
progressives who have offered this
critique from the left of President
Obama but when President Obama's
advisors are asked about this and
whether they're concerned especially
heading into real the reelection
campaign whether the they're sort of
base voters will be there for them they
point to pulling that shows that really
his support among the most liberal
voters in the country is still very
strong vote among support among
Democrats to support among
self-identified liberals so what they
say is that this critique that you're
offering is really not felt broadly than
for the most part people are happy with
the people on the left are happy with
this performance so how do you respond
to that wait well I think one of the
problems is is what do we mean by a
liberal those polls may be right I'm not
a liberal never have been I'm a
progressive and there's a very big
difference between being a progressive
and liberal the average working class
person in the
country the average senior citizen is
probably not a liberal what they are are
people who in many cases are struggling
right now very very hard trying to
survive and I think if you go up to the
average senior or the average working
class person and you say to them the
president told you that he was not going
to cut social security but now he's
thinking about doing that or he's
thinking about raising the eligibility
age for Medicare 267 what do you think
and they with my guesses they will say
we're not happy with that we think that
that's a bad idea they're not liberals
on the other hand you know the president
I think has done a reasonably good job
on and let me you know i'm not here to
beat up the president these are really
tough times when he came into office we
losing 700,000 jobs a month uh you know
so I'm not here to just be beating up on
the president but I think the president
and is his people are making a big
mistake if they think that at the
grassroots level there are not a lot of
working-class people who are the bulk of
people in this country who are not angry
and frustrated in disillusioned I think
they're making a mistake you know when
the president has he done a good job on
gay rights more or less he has maybe he
could have done more has he done a good
job in women's rights he's appointed two
women to the Supreme Court a lot of
women are very proud of that I'm very
proud of that but I think if you ask
people on economic issues has he stood
up the wall street in my view you have
crooks on Wall Street and I use that
word advisedly who's illegal behavior
whose greed whose recklessness put us
into this terrible recession now they're
doing just great do you think the
average American thinks that the
president has stood up to Wall Street in
the way that he should have said I think
probably not so young say you're calling
on a grassroots movement you're calling
on Americans to stand up Kevin referred
to your eight and a half hour speech
that you gave recently or is there
something that's coming down the pike
down the road trade legislation or
something that you're eyeing up that
you're saying I'm not going to stand for
it I'm going to go back to the floor and
I'm going to filibuster again well I
don't know that I'm gonna be
filibustering again but you are going to
hear my voice very loudly I think on
a couple of issues number one it's very
important that ordinary Americans stand
up right now in every one of our 50
states and say to the Congress say to
the supercommittee say to the president
that the negotiations that are taking
place right now with regard to deficit
reduction be fair that this committee
not come up with the proposal that
continues to go after some of the most
vulnerable people in this country that's
issue number one and the trade issue i
think is enormous it's not something
that is discussed very much in the
corporate media because there's a
general consensus that corporate media
likes unfettered free trade but i think
if you go to grassroots america and you
ask people whether nafta cafta permanent
normal trade relations with china has
worked for the middle class and working
class in this country they will tell you
no one hasn't so that's another issue
that i will be a pretty active on you
you said senator that you're not here to
beat up on president obama but you have
in the past talked about a primary
challenge to president obama and spoken
approvingly of one and i'm wondering if
you know who you have in mind for that
challenge and what you think that that
might accomplish if well what no i don't
have I don't know of anybody in mind but
I'm sure that there are serious and
smart people out there who can do it
here's the point if you're asking me do
I think at the end of the day that
Barack Obama is going to be the
Democratic candidate for president in
2012 I do but do I believe that it is a
good idea for our democracy and for the
Democratic body and I speak by the way
as an independent that people start
asking the president some hard questions
about why he said one thing during his
previous campaign is doing another thing
today on social security are on Medicare
I think it is important that that
discussion take place because i fear
very much in again going back to the
what liberals may think I don't know and
maybe that holding is is quite right but
i can tell you i do a radio show every
week over a million people hear it and
you know almost every state in the
country those are working class people
progressive people there is a lot of
disillusionment they want the president
the standoff
for the middle class for the working
class of this country and they want them
to take on big money interest in a way
that he has not done up to this point
senator we have about a minute left I
need to get this in as we talk on this
friday afternoon we're learning that a
divided US appeals court in Atlanta
ruled that a key provision of last
year's federal healthcare / overhaul law
is unconstitutional siding with a group
of 26 states as you know that challenged
the law the two-to-one ruling marks the
Obama administration's according to The
Wall Street Journal biggest defeat to
date in the multi-front legal battle
over the health care law and the
decision directly conflicts with a
ruling issued in June by a federal
appeals court in Cincinnati what's your
reaction my reaction is we have a
judicial system that is very political
where you have democratic judges my
guess is they're going to rule that this
provision is constitutional we have
Republican judges they're going to rule
otherwise i had i voted for health care
reform i think it did some good things i
don't think it went as far as it should
i believe in a medicare-for-all
single-payer program is the only way
that I know that can provide universal
health care and a cost-effective way to
all people senator Bernie Sanders we're
all out of time thank you for being our
newsmakers appreciate it thank you very
much let me turn to our reporters here
and in just Kevin if I can begin with
you what you hear from the senator and
the prospects for the super committee
that the all the members have been named
and and they're going to start with
their work well he's clearly frustrated
with the way the White House has been
handling this deficit confrontation over
the last year or so the line that we're
getting from Democrats in from Bernie
Sanders an independent seems to be to
hold the line and to try and protect
Medicare Medicaid Social Security these
giant social programs that are so
important to progressives and Democrats
it's he did seem to be open to the idea
that there might be some promise for
maybe chiefly symbolic tax reform to
come out of this process but I don't
know that there's a pessimistic outlook
on that yeah yeah Laura go ahead
what I took from this is that most of
what the debate around this whole
deficit-reduction question has been has
been that the assumption that Democrats
are willing to compromise and
Republicans are not Democrats led by
President Obama have said no we're
putting entitlements on the table you
somewhat reluctantly leader Pelosi and
Majority Leader Reid have gone along
with that and of course republicans have
not what he's basically saying is no no
no that's that's not how it's going to
be you know I'm speaking up for for the
left wing of the Democratic Party and
I'm not willing to make those
compromises so whether his view will
prevail at the end of the day you know
I'm certainly not predicting that I
think that chances are if this committee
comes up with a what Obama would call a
balanced deal with taxes and
entitlements that that probably will go
through but I think what he's trying to
do is and this is I think the role that
he typically does play in the Congress
is to provide some countervailing
pressure from the left to say that you
know don't take my compromise for
granted you know I'm not ready to cut
Social Security benefits i'm not ready
to raise the age of eligibility for
Medicare and those are both things that
the president obama has said straight up
he's willing to do Joe he seemed to be
comfortable with the idea of way the way
the super committee is going to work in
that he repeatedly said they're going to
be talking to the caucus they're gonna
be talking to the to the leadership that
patty murray's part of leadership that
this committee this so-called super
committee is going to be operating
differently than what we saw the Gang of
Six doing that was well privately behind
the scenes they weren't talking to other
people about it I think that I mean I
think that that was abundantly clear
when the name started coming out this
week many of these people were drawn
from sort of the second tier of
leadership on both sides and so I think
it's pretty clear that they'll be having
their you know marching orders from the
highest levels of leadership in Congress
and it won't be one of these sort of
freelance deals like the Gang of Six was
where these guys were often a primary
man and in fact there are demands that
this process be very open there's been
legislation filed requiring that its
meetings be public that the members of
the committee disclosed their campaign
contributions faster than usual
these sorts of things I think that'll be
a very open process but for those who
are who are hoping for a deal the idea
that they'll be accountable the
leadership is not entirely a bad thing I
mean ultimately in order you know the
Gang of Six is all well and good you can
love it but it's not law you know if you
want to see something actually become a
law really the way that these deals have
been done is through the leadership so
if you have people in there who are
essentially speaking for their leaders
jon kyl speaking for Senator McConnell
or are patty Murray speaking for
something to read that is not that made
that may help make this happen so of
course you know the difference of the
super committee is that it is guaranteed
if they get a majority vote an
up-or-down vote in the Congress which no
other plans have had that have had that
privilege so this this starts with a leg
up but the ID that they're in there
representing leadership is not
necessarily mean that there can't be a
deal it means there can't be a deal and
less leader sign on and what about the
role the White House in this well the
White House doesn't have a direct role
in this committee I think that they're
more of an influencer in terms of
setting the tone I think that perhaps to
senator Sanders dismay the White House
has set a tone for the Democrats which
is you know where we are willing to
compromise I think it would be just
unforced just cannot see it happening
where Republicans come to the table and
say I'm willing to give you billions of
dollars in tax increases and Democrats
say no so I think that they've that
they're there really to set the tone I'm
sure that we White House aides in the
room who are there to essentially be
whispering into the ears of the
Democrats about where the lines can be I
mean they've gone through several rounds
of this already two very intense rounds
of negotiations with Speaker Boehner
where they got very close to a deal so I
think that this whole question is a lot
less about how do we do it where can we
cut and more where's the politics of
this what are we willing to do and the
numbers the ideas there's plenty out
there for them if they want to take it
and Kevin what about senator Sanders
relationship with Senate Majority Leader
Harry Reid or Democratic leadership in
general do they feel the pressure from a
senator Sanders well you know he's
pretty far out on the left
and so I'm not sure that they pay that
much attention to what he says but he
says it loudly he says it clearly and
often and so they can't help but you
know he can't help but get their
attention from time to time minute and I
think that he does but getting back to
the point where I was making I think you
know there is a pop pretty powerful of
political dynamic going on here and I
think what we're going to see is this
debate carrying right on into next year
and straight out to the election I think
you can pretty easily see the next
year's election being almost a
referendum on these two deeply divided
policy positions Kevin Drawbaugh with
Reuters Laura Meckler with Wall Street
Journal thank you both thank you thank
you